stge is on his way over
here St is on his way over
here we
tried no you're not going anywhere not
with her in the
car then stop then stop Amber Amber no
just stop turn the car off okay will you
truh sters on his way over here we're
going to fit
Rickman all right come out here and
[Applause]
talk come out here and he'll talk to you
no what was it come
[Music]
on all right well let me
look I'm not
driving
I'm
I'll call you
back don't get this to me please look
come on let's talk I'm such um good
friends with you you can drive me home
please we're good friends that's why you
treated me the way you did but don't do
it come
on I can't come on and talk to us I
can't get out
the I'll do this summer
separately come
on
no I don't want we're going to talk back
here I don't know come back here and
talk you said you wanted to talk to him
let's come back here and talk come on
Amber Amber are you going to do fi
sobriety and stuff yeah I'll do anything
okay well then get out of the car we can
go under the awning or we can do it
right here and do come by I will lose my
kids come on let's do fil Sur I've give
it so much to all so so please
come on over
here I can
do please the only other place really is
the school right here
please look at
me can't placees the
school
where you
going
Amber okay oh let's go somewhere else
there's nowhere else we can go we're in
J are you going to do fil sobriety yes
will let's walk over here and do fil I'm
not doing it right here by the road I'm
going to take it as a refusal if you
don't walk over over here and do F
sobriety please walk over here I've
tried being
nice listen I've tried being nice Amber
all
right please don't make it just look out
for a white
truck please wait wait there's somebody
pulling
up just I don't have a choice Amber you
do I
don't
all right the first thing I'm going to
do is to fill uh the stagos okay is this
on camera
yes we can't I'm going to ask you I'm
going to check your eyes okay okay you
can do that but all right I can't I
can't be on camera stand with you're
going to be on camera Amber I can't be
on camera are you doing them or no yes
then you're going to be on camera this
whole thing's on
camera all right stand with your feet
together okay I'm going to check your
eyes keep your hands down there can you
see the tip of the pin yes follow with
your eyes and your eyes only okay don't
move your head all
right h Bob going to be in so much
trouble I know it's my
fault you got tape or something line can
we go quicker we're trying to find a
straight line Amber no I can do a
straight line it doesn't matter please
Justin please if he goes by I'll lose my
kids please why he's looking for tap
don't do that please here guess yeah
stand I
never the truck sitting down she's in
the other truck she can't see it from
here what am I go
say all right the next
yeah the next task I'm going to ask you
to do is to walk and turn Okay place
your left foot on the line and the heel
of your right foot in front of it within
touching okay all right so just like
this Left Foot Right Foot In Front okay
I wish we could do
this everybody out here stand okay
you're not starting till I tell you to
do you understand the direction so far
yes okay when I tell you to begin you'll
take nine Heel To Toe steps turn around
keeping one foot on the line and return
n he to toe steps so I don't know what
his truck is so you're going to take
nine Heel To Toe steps one 2 3 so on
until you get to nine on your ninth step
no not yet go back you're going to take
a series of several small
steps are you going to do them or
no are you doing them or no yes I doing
them okay on your ninth step you'll take
a series of small steps turning around
and continue down the line taking
several small steps to turn around while
walking look at watch your feet at all
times keep your arms at your side and
count the steps out once you begin do
not stop until the test is completed did
you understand all the instructions all
right go ahead and get in the starting
position your right foot in front of
your left
foot okay all right take nine H to toe
steps
how do you know I
can't refus them I'm not refusing you
didn't finish the task finish it but
there's people start
watching her go okay next task I want
you to do is the one-legged stand you
want to get your shoe back
on
put your shoe back on all right I want
you to stand with your feet together
hands down by your side will you answer
him for me all right hands down by your
side when I tell you to begin you're
going to lift your foot which one which
other foot you want okay it doesn't
matter whichever one you feel more
comfortable with lift it 6 in off the
ground you'll look at your foot and
you'll count out loud 1,1 1002 13 until
I tell you to stop you
understand all right hold on hold on let
me get this
ready you got a regular watch to time it
yeah stay right there that Joe I'm going
just stay right there that's not Joe
Amber that's not Joe that's Lieutenant
Hall stand back over there it's not Joe
go stand over there it's not Joe I'm
telling you that go stand back over
there you're not going to do the walking
turn are the one all right go back over
there
all right feet together hands down by
your side you remember what I told you
to do yeah okay feet together hands down
by your
side embarrassed I
can't turn around turn Amber turn don't
grab me turn around wait turn around
wait turn around I'll do it turn around
I'll do it
Amber turn around please turn around
don't turn no for one turn around don't
do
it Amber come you can take me home you
can do whatever Ambert
stop I can't I my please nothing we
tried that
earlier
D I don't have a
choice can you turn that off no we have
to have them on by
policy stop I'm not
done well for will you get her out of
the car hey no don't do it in front of
her
hey give me one hand what's
that I'm begging because of her who can
we have come Pi her up nobody you can
take her home and I'll go home how
she oh
my please God I want to lose my kids
please I've never asked for anything
from y'all know I've never I've done so
much
please please I
can't you know I can't I feel you can no
I can't I can't do this please put her
in my truck do me a favor her right over
there by theant I don't want come over
here so she don't see you Amber she
don't see you come over here come over
here do you want her to see you then
walk over
here you tied our hands I ever for
anything please
pleas don't get into
it my husband is going to take my kids
for me
please please look at me all right go
over here come
on come on don't you put on handc yes
come on no I'm
not you got anything on
you
no what are you resting me for have a
seat DUI have a seat du res I lose my
kiss resisting
have a
seat I I can't there's a step I'm going
to hold you will you have him come over
please
yeah
okay my decision so
I I understand that but the thing is is
you're asking me not to do my
job you know that and you know that's
wrong
okay no it's it's not even up for
discussion I know turn no ma'am you know
I can you call I
can't I
no I can't I can't you know I
can't and this this pains
me so who can I come pick up to get get
DCF
involved who can I
bring I cannot I
cannot
I
know no
ma'am you can tell
me you can tell me who can come get her
what you can talk we can talk I just
can't turn this off I get in trouble for
turning this off
I'm so close to retirement I can't risk
anything
okay so who can we have your daughter go
to your
folks then
who no
man it is what it is I this is just what
we have to
do yeah get my phone my phone yeah we'll
get your phone where's it at no
man
really
really I would never
please we met we'll get your stuff but
you got to stay in the back of the car
no is her phone and stuff in
there
okay how about a purse
um
hello
hello hello hello who is this this is
Lieutenant hall San Rose County
Sheriff's Office is this
uh this is Amber's mom yeah uh we've got
got Amber with us she's going to jail
for
DUI across the street from the school
can you come pick her up what school are
you at right right by J High
School yeah I'll be right there all
right thank you man
[Music]
bye
your mom's on her
way I don't have a whole lot of choices
here here's here's the
best I can't I cannot I'll take that
back I
won't okay I I've deputies arrested for
this same thing okay it is it is what it
is I can't turn it off you know that
okay your stuff is up front but that
that's I I can't do anything for you I I
can't now if you want to talk to the
sheriff and and and and the chief after
this no I don't okay all right yes ma'am
this is you know this is nothing
personal because I love you like a
sister and that makes it that much
harder I I can't you no ma'am I
cannot you can talk to him when you get
to the jail if you want to call him oh
no
ma' it's it's up in the
front get her out of
here leave those on the entire time
pleas
sh we
can't you can actually you can I promise
I
can't I'm not getting in
trouble on a little
slower I don't
know at least get on the property so we
can we got to call a
to to run out of
gas no no we're not laughing at
you this isn't funny at
all also be fny
we
separ most
likely what yo yeah
yeah yeah you can wipe your nose but I
can't wipe it right now did I get a
phone right
yeah so you could probably get numbers
off of
it pretty sure Joe already knows you
said you call me no I didn't call Joe
can I call you pleas don't please no
please it B me I'm going to lose my girl
please please
Amber Justin I can't I
can't I'm
not
no I'm going to lose my girl
please
have a
tissue once you get inside here you'll
be able to have it off we don't have a
tissue we don't have my fucking no we
don't have a tissue once you come in
there you can wipe your nose on your
sleeve you don't have to yell and cuss
at me like that I ain't done
nothing please don't want me in my
ass give me a minute